[Music]
when i walked in i said that i think i'm
gonna get ty off of the creative juices
in this place part of what they're doing
is two interviews a simulation but
another part of what i care about a lot
is synthesizing all that is into
something that's relatable for people
what I've come up with is something that
I think right now is temporarily called
seed theory and every human is the same
in terms of us being a seed but the DNA
inside of the seed is different each one
of us has different DNA inside to see
that tiny little bit that's different
and so that unique DNA is the way that
we're going to express ourselves fully
into the world and so here is a strange
X and y-axis that I will people are it
all explained in a little bit but just
the general idea I guess is that X the x
axis is time so this is when you're born
and this is like Age II let's say over
here and the y axis can be something
like the amount of actualization that
you have the month that your seeds DNA
has been fully expressed this seed has
roots on this side and it has branches
and leaves on this side on the on the
root side of things you need nutrients
every scene needs nutrients you need
love and compassion need air or water on
the nutrient side yes so you need all
those nutrients any of those nutrients
are missing one of the things that
happens is that the seed can get trauma
and if the seed gets trauma then the
seed
as potentially can not have its maximum
all ya actualizations did your seat have
trauma
I wonder how I wonder if you see you
know doesn't have at least a little bit
of trauma right if you do get a maximum
amount of nutrients let's say for the
scene you have a higher propensity to
rocket your cell phone this way if you
maybe don't have the nutrients your
accent accidentally brought yourself
this way this is why in so many
situations we see here on Stevenson
Street where our CEO is marketing seven
dish in the back alley Stevenson Street
there's so many humans that have had
deep trauma yeah
[Music]